Oh going miss my name is very bad
welcome to mEagle I wanted to do a
tomato what i chat with Brea's on omegle
i surprised whoever puts goodbye on
their interest on video so we'll see if
we get any funny reaction or stuff like
that well I see myself that's that's
good Stein I add that what beauty am i
talking about what who am I talking to
this beautify you talking to us if I
just don't have camera so I used to are
you okay you look very handsome by the
way extremely look at I keep getting
distracted well it was nice talking to
myself yeah
hey Adam maybe thanks something I'm Ken
arey no hate them I'm seeing a lot of
things okay cut
I don't get it Solly me like I wasn't
even gonna go on here I know I feel bad
because I know a lot of bros going here
to me to me but I've not on this side
that Officer tuck well I gotta run to
the next bro but it was really nice
meeting ya brother
ah looking a nerdgasm right now oh my
god
hey Donna okay
Mad Ants rather ready in case I am Lucas
fact I'm fanboying right now so bad oh
yeah right now but it's very unpopular
if it's a well if you do FBS it's it's
difficult to become popular I mean but
if you're enjoying making videos I mean
just keep keep making it I mean I I
started yeah exactly I started making a
Call of Duty videos and it was pretty
unpopular - and cuz I like Eliza you
brought us your friends for me and I
gotta roll to the next bro so here we
got alright my face Hey hmm maybe I
don't know
it's not me I'm Sonia I like how's a guy
now you did well I'm freaking out to
start engine no I always do this you've
been looking for a long time how long I
can't hear you it's really bad
connection
Hey there we go there we go the - don't
be sad perfect
oh my good again oh yeah right seriously
bro oh man I love you seriously are you
doing
oh my god Oh Cher's you I'm gonna die
Oh done don't die I won't take any
responsibility all right I just tried to
live you know okay like if it goes I'm
just a youth friend
that's awful t-shirts unlike it oh
really
yeah they're they're awesome I'm wear
than myself I like wait where are you
from are you American oh really yes so
lot of roads from there I think you're
like the she was a man yeah where are
you playing on the Xbox you know where
I'm at the same spot I just got another
screen so I got to screen oh I'll show
you
thank you nice house here and there's
the end of the screen there's a deck
wait were they I want to make a screen
oh sure of course yeah yeah I made it
stay awesome and fit yeah my bad
oh really
maybe how you then I love it a rat I'm
glad you down but no hey no it's fine
I bought a breakfast I am meeting with
this that it is but dumped done cry and
then cry it's fine that's fine
how's the gum right maybe that better oh
yeah how's it go man
ha ha oh absolutely
I was so lucky I just saw on Twitter and
I was it yeah Twitter brows okay well
make sure sorry how's it going in Italy
in Italy it's a pretty shitty weather
for the first time actually how's it
going wherever you are I'm in Scotland
and we've heard about it's been about
the best day in about six months for
that rain just at Ventura do you watch
anyone else on YouTube like you like
have any favorites on ug9 I really know
it's it I hear very few commentators
actually watch other people yeah what
about you do you watch anyone else yeah
I watch a lot of you know person called
penguins nah calls himself Craig goes oh
it's credit car yeah he did a he played
a lot of similar games like me every
time I play a game every one a sec I'll
create a cup laters Gavin I like he's
playing everything it's nice meeting you
rubbish wow that armpit is amazing
that's the best armpit they ever seen in
my life
more armpit action come on good Meg's
house it gun breath but the fire road
mix me with sinus oh yeah okay I got a
bit of youtuber here mom like I'm busy
I'm not paying thank you hey mom
suicide 35 he's a PI exit found him yes
I am
yes I am exactly him yes well it was
nice meeting you and your mommy
I do man this is a chronicle hey bad
done incredible just spit how's it go
man
going good hey breathless
how's it going I can't hear you by the
way
instead two of you are you twins ah
that's awesome thought it was your
mirror first I can hearing that okay all
right beautiful
I know right double brofist hey how's
your a um Molly's better what is it
sorry it's nice meeting you yeah I'm
sorry I'm glad you realize it's me
everyone is like oh you're the real yeah
time to prove that I'm real ever I got a
blame yeah I was like oh my god you say
okay it's not alright I did it I had
sorry I didn't mean you mm-hmm wait some
rooms for you that's a lot of breath hey
that's awesome thank you
cuz eyes meeting in broth a beauty
Hey yeah yeah
nice game how's it going good
oh my god it's going good I got your hey
I'm pretty good too pretty good I really
sorry I'm freaking out like this anyway
don't worry it's fine
the first view I ever saw me with
amnesia I think ah everyone wants to
initiate videos to learn everyone in
life all right
what broke is your friend for me on I
gotta run
but it was nice meeting you all right
thanks beauty holy [ __ ] I know it's on
me it's on me now tell me this oh yes
hey maybe good tasty buddy I've been
searching for like the last 20 minutes
you know ah lot of Nick hey those 20
minutes were worth it
my heart is pounding right now hi wow
this this is this is a good day my
friend
all right I'm glad I can make your day
good with that thing I'm so much do you
like my hi I love it
I'm sitting here I'm like there's 23,000
people I'm finding a needle in a
haystack there's no oh yeah it's pretty
crazy it's pretty crazy
I've been bumping into making my day add
don't worry nothing I'm not doing
anything literally very nice meeting you
best breakfast yeah it's a fake pimp I'm
sorry Tommy
it's fake Hey
hey today oh my god
how's the gun did it take a long time to
find me oh yeah bro fits in for me
alright your breasts ready
holy [ __ ] I look like [ __ ]
I've been editing this for hours I hope
you bros enjoyed it and there was a lot
of fun talking to me bro so I want to do
this again but it took me so much time
five hours at least
- just [ __ ] out of this also some
conversation might seem a little weird
it's just that I can't put every single
conversation now in there so some some
people they're just really quick because
I want to show at least but anyway like
if if you enjoyed this will help me out
a lot and scatter brush like and don't
go looking for me on amigo you probably
won't find me but if you want to chat
with other brothers go go right here but
anyway stay on some rest
hey caramel activated and I got happy
luggage up nice
got it doc doc
dynamic
ah